in san francisco just a couple nights
ago
three stores were ransacked and emptied
out
by mobs of looters in the same night
so mob of people armed with hammers
entered a jewelry star store in hayward
which is about 35 miles from san
francisco at 5 25 pm on sunday night
according to police take take a listen
to the operation
so you can see they just bust in there
is about what four or five guys and
hoodies
oh no more than that
six seven eight nine ten okay there's
one in the back
so say about ten or a dozen guys with
hoodies they're smashing open cases of
jewelry and they're all
running out of there with
with the goods then in the nearby town
of walnut creek about 30 minutes outside
of san francisco 80 people wearing ski
masks and carrying crowbars robbed in
nordstrom on saturday night
they
that broke into the store they pepper
sprayed and assaulted the employees they
grabbed a bunch of merch and they drove
away
eight people so this is i i want to be
precise it wasn't all in one night it
was over like a i don't know 36 hour 36
to 72 hour period eight people were
arrested friday after a louis vuitton
outlet was robbed in san francisco
multiple people broke the windows
emptied out the shop according to fox
the people who are weak on crime the
compassionate people the criminal
justice reform people they think this is
fine
they think it's fine to allow this to
happen
it's just stuff
the store owners they probably have
insurance
it's fine and they got their windows
smashed up a little and they you know
they're gonna have to close the shop for
you know a week or two but it's it's
fine
they actually a lot of these weak on
crime people think that this is just to
allow this to happen in particular
because the perps are black i'm not sure
if they were all black in all of the
instances but in the one that
we have video for they're black
and so a lot of especially white
liberals
and a lot of people who are weak on
crime will say well this is because of
historic racism
because of slavery the these they have
to rob the jewelry store they have to
and it's wrong
there are the victims the people robbing
the jewelry store they're the real
victims
and the people who own the jewelry store
who might be black who might be
some other race but
they're you know they're evil
because they have they have property and
they've got their lives in order and so
really we should just let these
criminals off the hook and if they are
arrested let's let them out on a really
low bond and
if they commit more crime hey that's
just
that's that's justice huh
but it's not legacy box is the best way
to preserve your past it's very simple
you have your photos and your home
movies and your tapes you send them in
to legacy box they will hand digitize
all of them to protect them against
flood and fire and old father time they
will send this back to you on the cloud
on a dvd on a thumb drive so it's future
proof forever you'll also get your
physical media back so you'll still have
those memories but while those physical
media will degrade over time the digital
ones will last forever it happened to me
that a beloved family member who had
died
i i lost all of the pictures of her i
lost them all and i was devastated by
this because i hadn't sent them into
legacy box
i didn't have the the didn't even know
about legacy box at that point then i
found some more instantly sent them in
it was so easy i got all my pictures
back and now they're future proof
forever legacy box is giving our
listeners their best deal of the year
during their black friday event visit
legacybox.com knowles to save an
unbelievable 65 percent with limited
quantities ready to ship
this deal will go fast go to
knowles for legacybox.com
off legacy box.com
knowles i'll get to that point that
rashida talib mentioned when she was
talking about how we how she doesn't
really want to empty all the jails but
she does want to empty all the jails and
she said it's about rehabilitation
sure
but in the jails they don't have enough
nice programs and they're not playing
enough games with the prisoners and so
they're not being rehabilitated
punishment
is rehabilitative
just
just punishment
including capital punishment by the way
hanging concentrates the mind the the
very fact of being punished for a crime
is rehabilitative
this is
not to bring up too many of my old dead
friends but this is what plato talks
about in gorgias
there's a great dialogue by plato and in
it socrates the character of socrates
explains that it is actually cruel not
to punish people for crimes
because it's not in their interest
because the people who are committing
these crimes have obviously disordered
desires and disordered habits and their
vices and they're basically on the road
straight to hell and it is an act of
mercy and compassion to punish them and
get them back on the straight and narrow
you think it's good for these robbers to
let them just continue in their life of
crime how do you think that's going to
end
how do you think that's going to end
it's going to end if they continue in
their life of crime they're either going
to get killed committing crime right
they're going to end up in some gang
shooting or some some burglary gone
wrong and they're or then they're going
to get killed or eventually they're
probably going to get arrested
and they're going to end up in prison
or even if they get away with all of the
crimes in this life they're going
straight to the bad place once they die
they have souls they actually do have
souls and the care of their souls is
important there is nothing
there there is a false compassion
in letting these guys off the hook
because of whatever kooky racial or
historical theories you have
but it is a false compassion and it's
cruel
this is adam smith actually the uh you
know from from whom we get uh much of
our economic philosophy and the wealth
of nations adam smith said cruelty
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent
it's a very stark way of putting it but
there is some truth to that
it's actually
it is actually it's cruel to the victims
of these people it's cruel to the shop
owners it's cruel to the future people
that these criminals are going to harm
and it's cruel to the criminals
themselves hold up stop collaborate and
listen collaborate with me please by
ringing that bell subscribe you'll get
notifications and if our
big tech friends don't send you
notifications i would really recommend
you head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play subscribe
to the audio podcast michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]